our next guest is an actor rapper TV
host police officer entrepreneur and
played a little bit of basketball at
some point you may remember him from the
commercial that probably ran maybe a
minute ago or perhaps he DJed your son's
Bar Mitzvah he seems to be everywhere
all the time it still manages to find
time to watch the Dan Patrick show
he claims McLovin is his favorite Dan
and although we suspect he's thinking of
the guy for the movies super bad
please welcome
Shack
good to see ya right yeah right there
before we get started okay yeah yeah
Alan Alan's my IT guy he's not very
smart okay let me tell you why okay cuz
I came and you pickpocket my IT guys
never do
I saw you grab his rear end so I've been
working on that lately yeah okay new
hobby stealing people's credit I like it
where it sounds like your show travel
the world in pickpocket people
somebody's looking audience yeah
Michigan Georgia do you have any
football ability of course I was
Allstate tighter you were okay
no I actually I actually started off
playing football in high school and a
guy your size one day hit me in the leg
and I stopped playing football was my
sport and then when I saw John contact
signed a big contract that's much nicer
true story so that's why I was that's
why I brought physicality to Indy I
guess so if not for John con CAC who was
nicknamed John contract right because he
got he got paid more and he should have
gotten that it was good maybe service
maybe service I was trying to be the
next to charge on you wanted to play for
the Cowboys yes and that's why Cowboys
fan oh you still Kelvin always the
Cowboys ever make you cry all the time
not good tears have you gone to a
Cowboys game a national question okay
which one is McLovin you watch this show
I do but I was well look look they both
wear glasses you know why guys
McLovin is like nervous I'm sorry no
much Pauli does that mean I'm not your
favorite an that anymore because I swear
I didn't bragging to everyone that Shaq
loves me for years
McLovin and you know and that's fritzy
I'm Ophir to in that seat season Shaq
you watch Sam's no no juice eaten okay
now his dad wanted him to go to Seton
Hall okay and he couldn't get in but he
named him Seaton after Seton Hall you
could go you know even with the name if
you didn't go to Elmo that's not McLovin
Paulie Paulie take off your glasses
there you go you know Stanley Roberts
used to be my favorite Center LSU but no
more big man yeah we appreciate y'all
Bruce you're good if you didn't go to
LSU where were you going I've visited a
North Carolina North Carolina State
Illinois at UNLV was it close love
Carolina State was proud I really I
really respected Jim Valvano and as you
know the joy sportsmen they had the
original Shaq Charles chuckles yeah and
that's where I got my name and my
identity from so I was actually a woman
wanting to play behind him but I said no
what I'm gonna be my own Shaq and I'm
gonna just take it take it down to Baton
Rouge
wait so you got your nickname from yes
Charles Shackleford yeah the original
Shaq reason was that I took his knee
pads to God I took everything you're a
little but you had a better career a
little better career than Charles
Shackleford something like that yeah
where do you think you rank working
where should you rank with big men I'm
over with big men I've never sat around
ranking myself okay how about I take you
out of it where where do you rank big
men I gotta go Bill Russell no more
Karim - probably will three king for and
probably me five so I would say top five
but my thing coming up is that you know
they mentioned all these great names
before me so I always said to myself I
can get my name mentioned with those
guys so I think I've I've done something
Leslie but did your dad I talked to
Barry Sanders about this all this all
the time his dad would never acknowledge
how great he was because he'd always say
you're no Jim Brown your dad being as
tough as Sarge was did he do that as
well to you he used to always take my
trophies and put them in a box
never displayed him no never displayed
so finally when I when I got a lot of
boxes a lot of buckets so finally when I
got older I asked him I said why'd you
do that he said because I never wanted
you to be satisfied so athlete passed
away seven years ago I retrieved all the
trophies and I made a trophy trophy room
and dedicate it to him in his honor and
I'm doing the same thing to my children
like I let him you know show the
trophies of what they win and I'll say
thank you very much cuz I never want
them to be satisfied either how's your
son doing he's doing fine he's doing
good he tell it was open-heart surgery
yeah it was open-heart surgery and he
was it was very scared and you know I
always always said to myself is it
stories that get me to calm down give it
the next level so right before the
surgery he was scared and you know he
had a little tear as I said you scared
he said yeah so he should be but when
you go in that room you're gonna meet a
young lady named anesthesia and you
won't remember anything he said what's
her name I said image anesthesia she's
gonna kiss you and then you know wake up
and everything
is that what looks like just go ahead
you're gonna suck so when he woke up and
I said do you remember anything he said
no as I told you anesthesia
how many surgeries have you attend and I
kinda like that and I kind of made it
you know comfortable for him to I said
look I never had heart surgery but this
will happen anesthesia
you're gonna wake up it's gonna be done
and you won't remember anything
you look like you could still play I
wish I could the money that they're
giving these bums I wish I could you
give me five minutes again yeah but yeah
but the people wouldn't want to see me
play five minutes that's why when I like
a golden state you could play five
million but I yeah but the people
wouldn't want to see me play that so the
reason why I wouldn't when I when I left
Boston like I had a two-year deal so I
got hurt career in injury
I couldn't rehab and came back for the
shack for a world tour but I felt like I
was robbing the people like there's you
know we charge people a lot of money for
tickets yeah and you know they used to
say in the 2815 show right Meg's going
six eight points I don't know I didn't I
didn't want to know charge the people
for that different teammates have told
me that you love to run around naked and
this is poor or gossip show sorry
oh okay but you would jump out and grab
guys then you would be naked I'll stop
it there's old people in the audience
including me yeah but you're okay the
best joke he ever played on somebody cuz
Berkeley was pretty good at playing
jokes on people did you ever you pranked
people yeah none of my jokes were pg-13
oh really
because you were running around naked
yeah what is this
Shaquille O'Neal joining us here in a
man cave I saw where you you brought up
something and I'm glad you did when
people talk about LeBron and Michael and
then you're saying wait why isn't Kobe
involved in this conversation why why I
don't know but he's in between them
playing wise it feels like he's a lot
more like Mike I'm a fan and I like
hearing these stories you know I like
hearing questions that will never be
asked for like who's more dominant Shaq
or we'll never know so when I just sit
back I just like like to you know listen
but it baffles me that nobody ever
brings his name up would you rather have
Michael as a teammate or LeBron well no
you have to take one so it's an open
draft you got first pick you got Mike or
you got LeBron Oh have a go Mike okay
did Mike talk trash to you yes of course
I mean what's he say to you it wasn't
really trash is just like he's the type
of player that he would say all right
I'm gonna go to this spot right here and
I'm gonna shoot to jump and like he
would do it Byrd used to do that too I
heard I know about dogs a bird would say
the famous one was Xavier McDaniel right
so there's a timeout and bird goes I'll
get the bowl right here X and I'm gonna
take the shot right in your face we're
gonna win the game
threw the ball into bird took shot won
the game feels extra Larry Bird
impression yeah so so exile get the ball
right here and I'm gonna get the ball on
a turn right in your face but I've been
working on you know my personation with
you let me hear it
hey Patrick shut the hell up alright
give me your impression of somebody you
got you don't do any impressions I tried
to call Stephen a with my text Johnson
boys but that don't worry son this is
Ted Johnson
I'd better stop talking about the
Cowboys he said it's not me it's not me
it's not a bad acts but you're from
Texas
no from New Jersey well you spend all
the time in Texas I'm all over if you
were Anthony Davis where do you want to
go I'm taking that 250 I'm standing I'm
staying in New Orleans do you worry
about the future of some of these
smaller franchises like New Orleans New
Orleans exist can they continue if
nobody wants to play I think if they
they make this trade I gotta get at
least three pieces that people people
would want to come and see I don't know
if if you don't get coos like you got to
get crunk on Kuzma does anybody want
Lonzo ball I don't know like you can't
you can't I can't have a point guard who
shoots 41% from the line well on the
free throw line
damn he's worse than me we found
somebody worse than you he shoots 41%
yes maybe you could help him do you miss
what do you miss about the game like you
miss anything I just you know I had my
time I just tried to give the people
enjoyment
as many championship as possible I don't
I don't really miss it
I'm just I just wish that uh you know Oh
a few more of the guys would say you
know I want to beat this guy rather than
play with that yeah because I never
would have said okay you know we keep
losing to Scottie and the Bulls I'm
gonna go play with the Bulls no I had
had a lot of times where I told my house
up because we lost and we just kept
losing and just Michael Jordan said
something to me after the 1996 Eastern
Conference Finals he said before you
succeed you must first learn to fail so
the reason I lost a lot of times it just
helped me getting over and then once I
finally got opened up you know I was
able to you know win three in a row but
you know that that sport times have we
seen like like rivals go go at it like
leg like me when I was coming up it was
always Boston another I was a Laker fan
and also used to beat us I had a guy his
name was Mitch riots he was Larry Barry
and I was Magic Johnson so mininum we
used to play a seven game series every
day every time Boston and when he
rattled me the whole year and every time
Lakers a win so that's what you know
sports is all about but would you tear
up your house yeah like what do you mean
tear up your house a rip off the toilet
bus a few windows break some dishes so
that I mean that add but that's decent
tab there you got a yeah there's above
just see you you'd especially toll it it
to you especially like if I had a
terrible known as the free-throw huh I
was just I was just like you don't go
crazy
very hard I know but then I would have
people say you know Shaq and practice
he'll make 20 in a row that's McLovin we
asked my guy Rob which one's McLovin
which one's McLovin rub you can catch
the big guy you can catch the big
podcast with Shaq new episodes every
Monday on podcast 1.com Apple podcast
you're also investing in the Alliance of
American football yes football doesn't
stop after this weekend
again in February 18th for injured
players hey Games it's on 10th yeah TNT
Bleacher Report Bruce your poor Steelers
fans what's up and what's the what's the
there's footage of you snoring yes
online I have a sleep apnea
no very bad and I know few people in
here small like like really loud like
how do you snore okay this is more true
no I don't yeah you do know I do know I
forgot we did two movies Nora cut it out
you smell so anyway I'm sound like
anybody here you snore definitely go see
a physician I just did partnership with
the company's deeper and I help you stop
you but how do you get somebody to sleep
with you if you snore like that I love
anyone sleep hey thank you for all the
times you've joined us we appreciate it
and you've been a great friend of the
show thank you should get to know some
of the guys on the show that's that's
Pauly over there
that's big lovin over there I swear I'll
go use my globe that that's Shaquille
O'Neal were baffled for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app